If you want more from the show, join The Rest Is History Club. And with Christmas coming, you can also gift a whole year of access to the history lover in your life. Just head to the rest is history.com and click gifts. This episode is sponsored by Hive. Britain revolutionised the future with the might of industrial power. But now you can transform your own energy future and take control with the power of hive. Hive makes the most of the sun, with solar panels turning sunlight into greener electricity and enabling you to sell excess back to the grid. And Hive's thermostats make it possible for you
如果您想了解更多节目内容，请加入“历史余韵俱乐部”（The Rest Is History Club）。随着圣诞节临近，您也可以为身边的历史爱好者送上一份全年会员资格作为礼物。只需访问 therestishistory.com 并点击“礼物”（gifts）即可。本期节目由 Hive 赞助。英国曾以工业力量的强大推动了未来的变革。现在，您也可以利用 Hive 的力量，掌控并改变自己的能源未来。Hive 充分利用太阳能，通过太阳能电池板将阳光转化为更环保的电力，并让您能够将多余的电量卖回电网。Hive 的恒温器让您能够
to heat your home without lifting anything more than a thumb and an impressed brow. Their heat pumps draw warmth from the air and they keep it exactly where you want it. No smoke, no waste. Hive's EV charger lets your car charge quietly overnight, recharging while you do too. Hive brings it all together, heating, charging and solar, managed from one simple app in a quiet revolution. In the long history of power, Hive helps you finally know yours. Head to hivehome.com to find out more, subject to survey and suitability. Hive app compatible with selected technology. Paid for a surplus requires SEG tariff.
只需动动手指、挑挑眉毛，就能调节家中的温度。他们的热泵从空气中汲取热量，并将其精准地保持在您想要的范围内。没有烟雾，没有浪费。Hive 的电动汽车充电器让您的爱车可以在夜间安静地充电，在您休息时同步补能。Hive 将供暖、充电和太阳能集于一身，通过一个简单的应用程序进行管理，实现了一场静悄悄的革命。在漫长的能源史上，Hive 终于让您掌握了自己的能源。请访问 hivehome.com 了解更多信息，具体取决于勘测和适用性。Hive 应用程序兼容特定技术。支付盈余电量需要 SEG 关税。
Hello everyone and I hope you had a wonderful Christmas. Now we have two festive treats coming up for you today and on Thursday. And these are two halves of a show that we recorded at the Royal Albert Hall on the 4th of May this year with a full orchestra and professional opera singers. And it has to be said, me. So like last year's episodes on Mozart and Beethoven, these episodes will be accompanied with music. The first episode, today's episode, is on Tchaikovsky,
大家好，希望你们度过了一个美好的圣诞节。今天和周四，我们将为大家带来两份节日大礼。这是我们今年 5 月 4 日在皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅录制的一场演出的上下两部分，现场有完整的管弦乐队和专业的歌剧演员。当然，还有我。所以，就像去年关于莫扎特和贝多芬的节目一样，这些剧集将伴随着音乐。第一集，也就是今天的节目，是关于柴可夫斯基的，
and Thursday's episode will be on Wagner. Enjoy. I'm I'm going to be able to be the I'm going to I'm I'm going I'm
周四的节目将是关于瓦格纳的。敬请欣赏。我……我将能够成为……我将……我将……我将……我……
I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm So, I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to be. And so,
我……我……我……我……我……所以，我将能够成为。我将成为。所以，
you know, I'm . I'm going to be the I'm going to be I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to
你知道，我……我将成为……我将成为……我将……我将……我将……
I'm a I'm the I'm a new, the way. The way, I'm going to be. And so on the
我是一个……我是……我是一个新的，方式。方式，我将成为。所以，在……
I'm not the way I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
我不是那种方式，我……我……我……我……我……我……
and I'm I'm and I'm I'm You know, the I'm going to be able to be.
而且我……我……而且我……我……你知道，我……我将能够成为。
Thank you. So welcome or welcome back to the rest history live with the orchestra. We have the amazing Philimonial Orchestra here with us. And today we're playing probably my two favorite composers, Tchaikovsky and Wagner. So here to tell you more about them are Tom Holland and Dominic Sandbrook. Hello Kensington Gore and welcome to the rest is history. Dominic, it's fantastic to be back at the Royal Albert Hall, isn't it? And thank you so much, everyone, for coming.
谢谢。欢迎来到“历史余韵”现场音乐会。我们今天有出色的爱乐乐团（Philharmonia Orchestra）与我们同在。今天我们将演奏我最喜欢的两位作曲家——柴可夫斯基和瓦格纳的作品。在这里为大家介绍他们的，是汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland）和多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）。你好，肯辛顿戈尔（Kensington Gore），欢迎来到“历史余韵”。多米尼克，回到皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅真是太棒了，不是吗？非常感谢大家的到来。
And wow, do we have a show this evening. We do indeed. So we will be talking about not just two of Oliver's favourite composers, but two of the greatest composers who have ever lived. Their lives, a brilliant window into the surging passions of the 19th century. So we'll be in Russia under the Tsars. We'll be in Germany, in the age of business. Mark, a world of romantic idealism, of sexual secrets, of Tom, some very pungent politics.
哇，今晚的节目真是精彩。确实如此。所以我们不仅要谈论奥利弗最喜欢的两位作曲家，还要谈论有史以来最伟大的两位作曲家。他们的生活是洞察 19 世纪汹涌激情的绝佳窗口。我们将置身于沙皇统治下的俄罗斯，置身于俾斯麦时代的德国，那是一个充满浪漫理想主义、性秘密和汤姆所说的非常辛辣的政治的世界。
Very pungent. We do like pungent politics on the rest is history. This show really does have it all. It really does. And you've already had a flavour of the music we're going to be hearing this evening. So that, of course, was the opening of Chikovsky's Ballet Swan Lake, first performed in 1877, and as Ollie said, played by the Philharmonia Orchestra and conducted by the equally brilliant Oliver Zethmann.
非常辛辣。我们在“历史余韵”节目中确实喜欢辛辣的政治。这个节目确实应有尽有。确实如此。你们已经领略了我们今晚将要听到的音乐。当然，那正是柴可夫斯基的芭蕾舞剧《天鹅湖》的开场，首演于 1877 年，正如奥利弗所说，由爱乐乐团演奏，并由同样出色的奥利弗·泽特曼（Oliver Zethmann）指挥。
And we should start by paying tribute to Oliver because these shows were his idea. He literally put the band together. And as you will find out, and as you've already discovered, with that wonderful performance of Swan Lake, he's not half bad at conducting either. Not bad at all.
我们应该首先向奥利弗致敬，因为这些演出是他的主意。他亲手组建了这支乐队。正如你们将要发现的，正如你们已经通过那场精彩的《天鹅湖》表演所感受到的，他的指挥水平也相当不错。一点也不差。
But let's get right into our first story, and this is the life of perhaps the most romantic and certainly the most flamboyantly Russian of all the great composers. Right, exactly. So, this whole show that we have for you this evening is very much a 19th century affair, and we're going to kick off in the year 1840,
但让我们直接进入我们的第一个故事，这是也许是最浪漫、当然也是所有伟大作曲家中最具俄罗斯风情的作曲家的生平。没错，正是如此。所以，我们今晚为大家呈现的整场演出都是 19 世纪的主题，我们将从 1840 年开始，
because that is the year that a young Piotr Ilyich-Cykovsky was born in a little iron-making town called Votsynsk, which is about 600 miles east of Moscow in the foothills of the Urals. So we are deep in the heart of Russia. We're in a classic Russian landscape. They're kind of churches with their golden domes, the vast fields, the deep birch and beach forests. It's the kind of landscape that is familiar if you've read Tolstoy or Dostoevsky or any of the great Russian novelist. Exactly, exactly.
因为那一年，年轻的彼得·伊里奇·柴可夫斯基出生在沃特金斯克（Votkinsk）的一个小铁器制造镇，距离莫斯科以东约 600 英里，位于乌拉尔山脉的山脚下。所以我们深入到了俄罗斯的心脏地带。我们置身于经典的俄罗斯景观中。那种有着金色圆顶的教堂、广阔的田野、深邃的桦树和山毛榉森林。如果你读过托尔斯泰、陀思妥耶夫斯基或任何伟大的俄罗斯小说家的作品，这种景观会让你感到熟悉。没错，确实如此。
So to give you a bit of context, Russia at the time is an autocracy ruled by the Romanov Tsars. And it's got this vast population of serfs and peasants. Now, it's often described as a backward country. But that's not necessarily true in every respect. Russia has been expanding at a colossal rate by 1840 when Charkovsky's born. It's a vast continental empire all the way from Finland and Poland to the Caucasus and the Pacific. And Tchaikovsky's family is doing well out of the Russian Empire, isn't it? So his father manages the local ironworks, they've got servants.
为了给大家一点背景，当时的俄罗斯是一个由罗曼诺夫沙皇统治的专制国家。它拥有庞大的农奴和农民人口。现在，它经常被描述为一个落后的国家。但这并不一定在所有方面都是正确的。到 1840 年柴可夫斯基出生时，俄罗斯正以惊人的速度扩张。它是一个从芬兰和波兰一直延伸到高加索和太平洋的庞大大陆帝国。柴可夫斯基的家庭在俄罗斯帝国过得不错，不是吗？他的父亲管理着当地的铁厂，他们有仆人。
And actually, shocking detail, Dominic, his – Chikovsky's mother's family are actually French. They are Huguenots who fled to Russia as refugees. So we're not holding that against them. No, we don't hold that against him. So he even actually had a French governess, and we know a few details about Tchaikovsky's early life from the French governor. She said he was a bright boy,
而且，多米尼克，还有一个令人震惊的细节，柴可夫斯基母亲的家族实际上是法国人。他们是作为难民逃到俄罗斯的胡格诺派教徒。所以我们并没有因此而对他们有偏见。不，我们不会因此而对他有偏见。所以他甚至还有一位法国女家庭教师，我们从这位法国女教师那里了解到了柴可夫斯基早年生活的一些细节。她说他是个聪明的孩子，
but incredibly sensitive. She said he was as brittle as porcelain, a child of glass. And Tom, very much like our goalhanger stablemates. We actually have Rory Stewart with us in the audience, and nobody would ever say Rory was as brittle as porcelain. Of course not. Of course not.
但极其敏感。她说他像瓷器一样脆弱，是个玻璃做的孩子。汤姆，这很像我们“高尔汉格”（Goalhanger）的同事。我们今天观众席里有罗里·斯图尔特（Rory Stewart），没人会说罗里像瓷器一样脆弱。当然不会。当然不会。
So the Tchaikovsky's, they're not a tremendously musical family, actually, as it happens. I mean, they do have a piano, but basically everyone who's middle class in the 19th century has a piano, and none of them are very good at playing it. No, they're not terribly good at it, but then one day, Piotr's father, Ilya, comes home from St. Petersburg. He's been in a business trip, and he has this kind of barrel organ called an orchestrion. And the point of this machine is that would basically mimic the sound of an entire orchestra.
所以，柴可夫斯基一家并不是一个特别有音乐天赋的家庭。我的意思是，他们确实有一架钢琴，但基本上 19 世纪的中产阶级家里都有钢琴，而且他们中没有谁弹得特别好。不，他们弹得并不怎么样，但有一天，彼得的父亲伊利亚从圣彼得堡出差回来。他带回了一种叫“管弦乐器”（orchestrion）的自动风琴。这种机器的意义在于，它基本上可以模仿整个管弦乐队的声音。
So we wouldn't actually need the Philharmonia if we could only invest it in one of those. Oliver's life would be so much easier. So this is how the young Chikovsky falls in love with music. Basically, you feed a sheet into this thing, and you turn it. It could be Mozart's greatest hits, and away you go. And actually, it's Mozart that Chikovsky really falls in love with. Mozart becomes his great hero. So in the next few years, the family move around quite a bit.
所以如果我们能投资买一台那个，我们其实就不需要爱乐乐团了。奥利弗的生活会轻松得多。这就是年轻的柴可夫斯基爱上音乐的方式。基本上，你把乐谱塞进这个东西里，然后转动它。它可以是莫扎特的金曲，然后你就开始了。事实上，柴可夫斯基真正爱上的是莫扎特。莫扎特成了他伟大的英雄。所以在接下来的几年里，他们一家搬了好几次家。
They see the cities, St. Petersburg and Moscow. They go to different places in the Urales. And I often wonder whether this is, the fact that they move around, whether this gives Chikovsky one of his defining traits, which is an extraordinary affinity with the people and landscape of Russia, this intense sense of patriotism. Much later on in life, he wrote, I have never come across anyone more in love with Mother Russia than me.
他们看到了圣彼得堡和莫斯科这些城市。他们去了乌拉尔山脉的不同地方。我经常想，他们搬家这件事是否赋予了柴可夫斯基他最显著的特征之一，那就是与俄罗斯人民和景观的非凡亲和力，这种强烈的爱国主义感。晚年时他写道：“我从未见过比我更热爱俄罗斯母亲的人。”
I love Russian people, the Russian language, the Russian way of thinking, I love the sacred legends of the dim and distant past, I love it all. But I mean, almost the paradox of this is that even as it's very Russian, It's also very European, isn't it? Because European culture is still very marked by romanticism, by the cult of landscape, the cult of sensibility, and I guess above all the cult of nationalism. So all sorts of writers and composers across Europe,
“我热爱俄罗斯人民、俄罗斯语言、俄罗斯的思维方式，我热爱遥远过去的圣洁传说，我热爱这一切。”但我的意思是，这几乎是一个悖论，尽管它非常俄罗斯，但它也非常欧洲，不是吗？因为欧洲文化仍然深受浪漫主义、景观崇拜、感性崇拜，以及我想最重要的是民族主义崇拜的影响。所以欧洲各地的各种作家和作曲家，
not just in Russia, are fascinated by folk traditions and history and ancient myths and legends. And we will be coming on to someone else who is interested in myths and legends in the second half. We will indeed. But at the time when he was growing up, I think to his family, the idea that Chikovsky would be the great Russian musical vehicle for all this
不仅仅是在俄罗斯，都对民间传统、历史以及古老的神话传说着迷。我们将在下半场谈到另一位对神话传说感兴趣的人。我们确实会。但在他成长的过程中，我想对于他的家人来说，柴可夫斯基会成为这一切伟大的俄罗斯音乐载体的想法，
would have seemed relatively unthinkable. Because although they have a piano, most Russians, as you said, have a piano, most Russian middle-class families, but in Russia, middle-class boys don't go on to become musicians. So when they go to the opera house or the concert hall, the musicians they hear playing are touring Western European musicians. It's not seen as a proper thing for someone like Chikovsky. to do? So to begin with, Tchaikovsky doesn't pursue a musical career. He pursues a much more
似乎是相对不可想象的。因为虽然他们有钢琴，正如你所说，大多数俄罗斯中产阶级家庭都有钢琴，但在俄罗斯，中产阶级男孩不会去成为音乐家。所以当他们去歌剧院或音乐厅时，他们听到的音乐家都是巡演的西欧音乐家。这在当时看来并不是像柴可夫斯基这样的人该做的事。所以起初，柴可夫斯基并没有追求音乐事业。他追求的是一个更
glamorous profession, which is to become a civil servant. And I'm not joking when I say that, because, I mean, anyone who's read a Russian novel will know that to be a civil servant is really quite something. Very prestigious vacation, very difficult to get into. Right, it is difficult to go into. So when he's 12 years old, his parents sent him to a boarding school in St. Petersburg, which is called the School of Jury's Prudence. That's where you learn to become an official. So he wears a military uniform. He has to swear an oath at the age of 12 to God, throne and motherland. And he has to work every day from 6 o'clock in the morning until 10 o'clock at night. And that is the routine, Tom, that we have replicated with our own producers, Theo and
迷人的职业，那就是成为一名公务员。我这么说并不是在开玩笑，因为任何读过俄罗斯小说的人都知道，成为一名公务员确实是一件了不起的事情。非常令人向往的职业，非常难进入。没错，确实很难进入。所以当他 12 岁时，父母把他送到了圣彼得堡的一所寄宿学校，叫法律学校（School of Jurisprudence）。那是你学习成为官员的地方。所以他穿着军装。他必须在 12 岁时向上帝、王位和祖国宣誓。他必须每天从早上 6 点工作到晚上 10 点。汤姆，这就是我们与自己的制片人西奥（Theo）和
Tabby. I think, I think, Dominic, you are flattering Theo there, who is never knowingly up before midday, but nice, you know. It's sweet of you to say that. So Chikovsky is there in this school until he's 19 and then he becomes an administrative assistant at the Ministry of Justice. But all this time he's been into his music. He's been writing waltzes and songs and things. And unlike most civil servants, he becomes a real dashing sort of swashbuckling man about town. And I have to say his dad is very impressive at this point. So he's about 21 and his dad sits him down and says, this civil servant thing, It's obviously not you. Why don't you go for music?
塔比（Tabby）所复制的作息。汤姆，我觉得你在恭维西奥，他从来没在中午之前醒过，但你这么说很贴心。所以柴可夫斯基在学校一直待到 19 岁，然后成为司法部的一名行政助理。但在这段时间里，他一直沉迷于音乐。他一直在写圆舞曲、歌曲之类的东西。而且与大多数公务员不同，他成了一个真正时髦、那种在城里闯荡的冒险家。我必须说，他父亲在这一点上非常令人钦佩。所以他当时大约 21 岁，他父亲坐下来对他说：“这个公务员的事情，显然不适合你。你为什么不去搞音乐呢？”
Why don't you try it? And so Chikovsky says, well, if Dad's saying that, I might as well. And he does. And the timing is perfect because the following year in 1862, St. Petersburg's first musical conservatory opens its doors, and Chikovsky is there.
“你为什么不试试呢？”于是柴可夫斯基说：“好吧，既然爸爸这么说了，那我就试试吧。”他确实这么做了。时机非常完美，因为第二年，即 1862 年，圣彼得堡的第一所音乐学院开门招生了，柴可夫斯基就在那里。
Right. He's one of the very first students. And like a lot of students, he reinvents himself. He grows his hair long. He wears much more sort of raffish clothes. It's a kind of Quine, kind of Carnaby Street in the 16th? Well, as we will discover, slightly more San Francisco in the 60s. Yes, of course.
没错。他是第一批学生之一。像许多学生一样，他重塑了自己。他留长了头发。他穿得更时髦、更放荡不羁。这有点像 16 世纪的卡纳比街（Carnaby Street）？嗯，正如我们将要发现的，更像是 60 年代的旧金山。是的，当然。
So he's sort of turning himself into an artist with a capital A. And eventually he gets a job in Moscow teaching music at the new conservatory there. So now he really has become a proper kind of working musician, a working composer. He teaches students. He writes songs, he writes little operatic pieces, a first symphony. And all the time, he is developing this. intensely romantic style, sometimes grand and sweeping, but sometimes very kind of delicate and intimate. Yeah, and we're going to hear an example of that right now, aren't we? And Dominic,
所以他把自己变成了一个大写的“艺术家”。最终，他在莫斯科的一所新音乐学院找到了一份教音乐的工作。所以现在他真正成为了一名合格的职业音乐家、职业作曲家。他教学生。他写歌，写一些小歌剧，还有第一交响曲。而且一直以来，他都在发展这种极其浪漫的风格，有时宏大而奔放，有时又非常细腻和亲密。是的，我们现在就要听一个例子，不是吗？多米尼克，
it's a song he wrote in 1869. Yeah. But because I don't speak Russian and because you are the master of tongues, perhaps you'd like to give the Russian title first before we come on to the English translation. Yeah. Close your ears, please, Oliver. It is niet cholko, tot, kutuzna. What is it? You heard. You all heard. Which, Tom, as you will know, translates as none but the lonely heart.
这是一首他 1869 年写的歌。是的。但因为我不懂俄语，而且你是语言大师，也许你想在进入英文翻译之前先说出俄语标题？好的。请捂住耳朵，奥利弗。是“Niet cholko, tot, kutuzna”。是什么？你们听到了。你们都听到了。汤姆，正如你所知，翻译过来就是“唯有孤独的心”（None but the Lonely Heart）。
And a great favourite of Frank Sinatra, who recorded it four times. And sadly, Frank can't be with us this evening. But it doesn't matter because we have an even better singer than Sinatra. And that is Marta Fontanel-Simmons, who is going to perform None but the Lonely Heart for us now.
这是弗兰克·辛纳屈（Frank Sinatra）的最爱，他录制过四次。遗憾的是，弗兰克今晚不能和我们在一起。但这没关系，因为我们有一位比辛纳屈更好的歌手。那就是玛尔塔·方塔内尔-西蒙斯（Marta Fontanel-Simmons），她现在将为我们演唱《唯有孤独的心》。
Now, Who knew, who know, Svite, I'm jasd'n, I'm jasdun. Oh, my God, how I stradall, and how I straddle. Look, I'm looking I'm in D'Aldnizzi, I'm from here, I'll gnailkne a-knit-n-lok-a-law-o-kaw. Oh!
现在，谁知道，谁知道，Svite，我……我……哦，天哪，我多么痛苦，我多么痛苦。看，我……我……我……
Oh, my name, I'm blitzel, Oh, Luke. Oh, that only who knows I'm sorry, I'm sorry, oh, oh, how I'm
哦，我的名字，我……哦，看。哦，只有知道的人……我很抱歉，我很抱歉，哦，哦，我多么……
how I'm scared, and how I strah, oh, My blood-ca-giat-ca-gast-Gradal, I beg-last-a-blood. Sjah Grewd callit, who's my name's Ville d'nese bade?
我多么害怕，我多么痛苦，哦，我的……我恳求……
I'm sorry, no, I'm yet, I'm yot, how I stradal, and how I stradal, and how like I stuards do. Thank you. You see, who needs Frank Sinatra? That was Marta, Fontaineau-Simmons, and the Philharmonia Orchestra, conducted by Oliver Zephemann. Absolutely wonderful. Now, Tom, I know your Russian is absolutely perfect, so you won't need me to translate any of those lyrics.
我很抱歉，不，我……我……我多么痛苦，我多么痛苦，我多么像……谢谢。你看，谁需要弗兰克·辛纳屈？那是玛尔塔·方塔内尔-西蒙斯和爱乐乐团，由奥利弗·泽特曼指挥。真是太棒了。现在，汤姆，我知道你的俄语非常完美，所以你不需要我翻译那些歌词。
But just in case... For everyone else? Yeah, for everybody else. None but the lonely heart can know my sadness, alone and parted, far from joy and gladness. And they capture something, I think, that is central to Tchaikovsky's reputation. the great secret drama of his life, which is, of course, his love life. So, Chikovsky probably first fell in love when he was a teenager at the School of Jurisprudence,
但以防万一……为其他人？是的，为其他人。唯有孤独的心才能了解我的悲伤，孤独而分离，远离欢乐与喜悦。我认为，它们捕捉到了柴可夫斯基声誉的核心，即他生活中伟大的秘密戏剧，当然，就是他的爱情生活。所以，柴可夫斯基可能第一次坠入爱河是在他十几岁在法律学校的时候，
and his love object was another student, a young man called Sergei Kiref, who was about four years younger than himself. Now, it probably wasn't a physical relationship, probably a case of adoration from afar, but then Chikovsky fell for another young man Alexei Apuktin who ended up becoming a poet and this probably was a physical relationship and it was the first of many in Chikovsky's life and I think it would be fair to say that the vibe of Russia in the 19th century isn't massively kind of gay friendly
他的爱慕对象是另一名学生，一个叫谢尔盖·基列夫（Sergei Kiref）的年轻人，比他小四岁左右。现在，这可能不是一段身体上的关系，可能只是远距离的崇拜，但后来柴可夫斯基爱上了另一个年轻人阿列克谢·阿普克廷（Alexei Apuktin），他后来成为了一名诗人，这很可能是一段身体上的关系，这是柴可夫斯基一生中许多段关系中的第一段，我认为公平地说，19 世纪俄罗斯的氛围并不是非常对同性恋友好，
is it so we are doing a series starting tomorrow actually on Peter the Great and he had decreed the death penalty for any hint of homosexuality in the army back in 1706, and then in 1832, Nicholas I, another Tsar, had declared that any civilian convicted of homosexual behaviour would be packed off to Siberia, which, to be fair, basically seems to be the response of Russian Tsars to almost anything. But most of these punishments were never carried out. And I think that's because in 19th century Russia, homosexuality, it wasn't, it didn't. It didn't. It didn't. It
是吗？所以我们明天实际上要开始一个关于彼得大帝的系列节目，他在 1706 年就下令对军队中任何同性恋倾向处以死刑，然后在 1832 年，另一位沙皇尼古拉一世宣布，任何被判有同性恋行为的平民都将被流放到西伯利亚，公平地说，这似乎是俄罗斯沙皇对几乎任何事情的反应。但这些惩罚大多从未执行过。我认为这是因为在 19 世纪的俄罗斯，同性恋，它并没有……它并没有……它并没有……它
didn't kind of define you. It wasn't an identity. It was seen as just being a taste. And so if you had money and if you had connections, the chances of prosecution, let alone conviction, were actually very, very small, weren't they? Yeah, they were small. It's really interesting. So as you said, homosexuality is condemned as a vice by the Orthodox Church, but it's fascinating that in all Chikovsky's life, there is only one tiny hint of scandal or public criticism. And that's a newspaper article in 1878 that was sort of muttering darkly about the teacher's love affairs at the Moscow Conservatory. And even though Chikovsky visited gay brothels, he went cruising in parks,
并没有定义你。它不是一种身份。它被视为仅仅是一种品味。所以如果你有钱，如果你有关系，被起诉甚至被定罪的可能性实际上非常非常小，不是吗？是的，很小。这真的很有趣。所以正如你所说，同性恋被东正教谴责为一种恶习，但令人着迷的是，在柴可夫斯基的一生中，只有一次微小的丑闻或公众批评的暗示。那是一篇 1878 年的报纸文章，对莫斯科音乐学院老师的恋情进行了阴暗的嘀咕。尽管柴可夫斯基去过同性恋妓院，他在公园里寻找伴侣，
he made no secret of his affection for handsome young men, that was really the only tiny hint of public scandal in all his life. But that hasn't stopped Chikovsky's biographers since from kind of basically tearing each other to shreds over the question of whether he felt haunted by his sexuality or whether he was completely mellow about it. Yeah, so in the Soviet Union, this was a big problem for historians and biographers of Tchaikovsky.
他毫不掩饰自己对英俊年轻男子的喜爱，那确实是他一生中唯一一次微小的公众丑闻暗示。但这并没有阻止柴可夫斯基的传记作者们此后基本上为了他是否被自己的性取向所困扰，或者他是否对此完全坦然的问题而争得面红耳赤。是的，所以在苏联，这对柴可夫斯基的历史学家和传记作者来说是一个大问题。
And they went out of their way to play down his sexuality, and in fact, Soviet historians effectively went into the archives to erase material that they thought presented him in a bad light. But in the West, particularly, I have to say in Britain, people tended to play it up. So in the 20th century, Chikovsky became in Western scholarship. He was seen as the gay composer.
他们竭尽全力淡化他的性取向，事实上，苏联历史学家有效地进入档案，删除了他们认为对他形象不利的材料。但在西方，我必须说在英国，人们倾向于夸大它。所以到了 20 世纪，柴可夫斯基在西方学术界成了“同性恋作曲家”。
So first of all, kind of condemned as a hysterical neurotic and then held up as a hero of gay rights. But I mean, not saying that he's a hysterical neurotic, but there are hints that he struggled with his sexuality, aren't there? I mean, he finds it hard to sleep at times. He seems to become depressed. He gets, he has kind of nervous breakdowns occasionally. Yes, but that said, most recent writers point out
所以首先，他被谴责为一个歇斯底里的神经质，然后被捧为同性恋权利的英雄。但我的意思是，并不是说他是一个歇斯底里的神经质，但有迹象表明他曾与自己的性取向作斗争，不是吗？我的意思是，他有时发现很难入睡。他似乎变得抑郁。他有时会精神崩溃。是的，但话虽如此，最近的作家指出
that he led a very active and indeed very colourful love life. In fact, I think we can safely say a little too colourful for 21st century tastes. Because he almost always fell for men who are a lot younger than himself. Boys. Well, he was particularly drawn to boys of about 14 or 15, which a lot of people may find very unsettling. So, I mean, he's kind of the Russian Oscar Wilde maybe,
他过着非常活跃且确实非常丰富多彩的爱情生活。事实上，我认为我们可以肯定地说，对于 21 世纪的口味来说，有点太丰富多彩了。因为他几乎总是爱上比自己年轻得多的人。男孩。嗯，他特别被 14 或 15 岁左右的男孩所吸引，这让很多人可能会感到非常不安。所以，我的意思是，他也许是俄罗斯的奥斯卡·王尔德，
in that sense. So a kind of a great gay icon, but a lot of his gay relationships are with people who are much younger than him. And so inevitably there is a kind of power differential there, isn't it? Yeah, I think that's fair to say. I think it's a pattern you see again and again in Chikovsky's life. So there's a musical prodigy called Vladimir Shilofsky, who's 14. Then there's a 15-year-old, a music student called Edward Zach. And Chikovsky had a real passion for him. and Zach actually ended up taking his own life a few years later. And a lot of this story is very murky because it was effectively erased by Soviet censors.
从这个意义上说。所以是一个伟大的同性恋偶像，但他许多同性恋关系的对象都是比他年轻得多的人。所以不可避免地存在一种权力差异，不是吗？是的，我认为这样说是公平的。我认为这是你在柴可夫斯基一生中一次又一次看到的模式。所以有一个叫弗拉基米尔·希洛夫斯基（Vladimir Shilofsky）的音乐神童，他 14 岁。然后是一个 15 岁的音乐学生，叫爱德华·扎克（Edward Zach）。柴可夫斯基对他有真正的热情。而扎克几年后实际上选择了自杀。这个故事的很多部分非常模糊，因为它被苏联审查员有效地抹去了。
So it's very hard to say what exactly happened between them. But what we do know is that Chikovsky was absolutely devastated afterwards. And one of his biographers says, you sense the presence of a complex and intense psychodrama that is almost entirely hidden from view. And hidden from view, presumably because Tchaikovsky himself is trying to bury it. And so there's doubly a kind of darkness, a darkness that Tchaikovsky wants to bury the memory of this in. But also a kind of personal darkness that Tchaikovsky is feeling, kind of element of self-hatred, perhaps, almost depression.
所以很难说他们之间到底发生了什么。但我们所知道的是，柴可夫斯基事后彻底崩溃了。他的一位传记作者说，你感觉到了一种几乎完全隐藏在视线之外的复杂而强烈的心理剧的存在。隐藏在视线之外，大概是因为柴可夫斯基自己试图掩盖它。所以这是一种双重的黑暗，一种柴可夫斯基想要埋葬这段记忆的黑暗。但也有一种柴可夫斯基感受到的个人黑暗，一种自我厌恶的成分，也许，几乎是抑郁。
I think that's fair to say. I mean, after Zach's death, he goes into this deep, deep depression. And then, as so often, he emerges with a great burst of energy. So it's 1875. He comes out of this depression. and his commission to write a ballet, and that became the piece we heard at the beginning, Swan Lake, one of the most beloved pieces in the whole canon.
我认为这样说是公平的。我的意思是，在扎克死后，他陷入了这种深深的抑郁。然后，正如经常发生的那样，他以巨大的能量爆发出来。所以那是 1875 年。他走出了这种抑郁，并受命创作一部芭蕾舞剧，那变成了我们在开头听到的那部作品《天鹅湖》，整个经典曲目中最受喜爱的作品之一。
And then a year after that, he falls in love again with a violinist called Joseph Kotech, who was then 21. When, for hours on end, I hold his hand in my own, passion rages within me with unimaginable force. My voice shakes like that of a youth, and I speak a load of nonsense. And Dominic, that is Tchaikovsky, not you. That's not me on, no.
一年后，他又爱上了一位叫约瑟夫·科泰克（Joseph Kotech）的小提琴家，当时他 21 岁。“当我有几个小时的时间握着他的手时，激情在我内心以不可想象的力量狂暴。我的声音像年轻人一样颤抖，我说了一堆废话。”多米尼克，那是柴可夫斯基，不是你。那不是我，不。
That's not me talking about Theo, Tom. Yeah. That's Tchaikovsky talking about this bloke. So this is a letter that he writes to his brother Modest, his younger brother Modest, who is also gay. And they would talk quite openly about all of this, which leads me to think that Chikovsky's probably not quite as tortured and as repressed as we often assume. I suppose another issue is, I mean, honestly, I mean, who ultimately cares? Does this matter? Of course, in the immediate aftermath of Chikovsky's death,
那不是我在谈论西奥，汤姆。是的。那是柴可夫斯基在谈论这个家伙。所以这是他写给他弟弟莫杰斯特（Modest）的一封信，他弟弟莫杰斯特也是同性恋。他们会非常公开地谈论所有这些，这让我认为柴可夫斯基可能并不像我们通常假设的那样痛苦和压抑。我想另一个问题是，我的意思是，老实说，我的意思是，最终谁在乎呢？这重要吗？当然，在柴可夫斯基去世后的直接影响中，
there are lots of people who feel it does matter. So Chikovsky dies, and Tolstoy, who by this point is about 810, he writes, there is always something not quite clear about him, more as a man than as a musician, which I'm guessing is a reference to his sexuality, and certainly in the decades that follow Chikovsky's death, there are critics who condemn his music as an erotic and effeminate, presumably they are saying that because they're not really talking about his music at all.
有很多人觉得这很重要。所以柴可夫斯基去世了，托尔斯泰，当时大约 810 岁，他写道：“关于他，总有一些不太清楚的地方，作为一个人比作为音乐家更是如此”，我猜这是指他的性取向，当然在柴可夫斯基去世后的几十年里，确实有评论家谴责他的音乐是“色情和女性化”的，大概他们这么说是因为他们根本不是在谈论他的音乐。
They're talking about his posthumous reputation. Right. But I think with all of this stuff, it's important not to sort of blow it out in proportion. So there's a great music critic at the 20th century called Richard Taroskin. And he wrote a brilliant, brilliant essay on all this, which actually Oliver, our conductor, put me on to. And Taraskin said, look, we should stop seeing Chikovsky as this angst-ridden, guilt-ridden, kind of neurotic artist. By and large, this is somebody who is very successful. who has loads of fun, actually loads of money,
他们是在谈论他死后的名声。没错。但我认为对于所有这些事情，重要的是不要把它夸大。所以 20 世纪有一位伟大的音乐评论家叫理查德·塔鲁斯金（Richard Taruskin）。他写了一篇关于这一切的精彩绝伦的文章，实际上是我们的指挥奥利弗向我推荐的。塔鲁斯金说，看，我们应该停止把柴可夫斯基看作是这个充满焦虑、充满内疚、那种神经质的艺术家。总的来说，这是一个非常成功的人，
and is generally pretty happy. All of that said, Tom, you are right that there are issues, shall we say, because in 1876 he does basically the most unexpected and implausible thing you could possibly imagine. I mean, so unexpected, so implausible, that I think we should probably have a bit of music beforehand to brace ourselves for it. And what we're going to hear now is a piece he wrote in 1878
他有很多乐趣，实际上有很多钱，而且通常相当快乐。话虽如此，汤姆，你是对的，确实存在一些问题，我们可以这么说，因为在 1876 年，他基本上做了你能想象到的最出乎意料和不可思议的事情。我的意思是，太出乎意料，太不可思议了，以至于我想我们可能应该在之前听一点音乐来为它做好准备。我们现在要听的是他 1878 年写的一部作品，
amid the great emotional crisis of, spoiler alert, Tchaikovsky's marriage. And that is what we will be coming to in a moment. But first, the third movement of his violin concerto, played by our soloist, The Brilliant Leia Zoo. Enjoy. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be.
在柴可夫斯基婚姻的巨大情感危机中，剧透预警。这就是我们稍后要谈到的。但首先，他的小提琴协奏曲的第三乐章，由我们的独奏家，出色的莱娅·祖（Leia Zoo）演奏。敬请欣赏。我将成为。我将成为。我将成为。
And... No, I'm... ...there not... ...and... ...and... ...there... ...and... ...and...
而且……不，我…………那里没有…………而且…………而且…………那里…………而且…………而且……
...a... ...or... You know. Oh. Yeah. I'm going to be able to be able to do. I'm going to be. I'm going to be able to be.
……一个…………或者……你知道。哦。是的。我将能够能够做。我将成为。我将能够成为。
I'm going to be. I'm going to be. So, you know, I'm I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to be. And then
我将成为。我将成为。所以，你知道，我……我将能够成为。我将成为。然后
. And... ...andahs ...and ...and ...and ... ...and
。而且…………而且……而且……而且……而且……
... ... I'm gonna'n't I'm gonnae'n't I'm gonna'n't I'm gonna'n't I'm not I'm going to be the
…………我将……我将……我将……我将……我不是……我将成为……
I'm going to be I'm going to I'm going to and I'm going to I'm going to I'm I don't know. I'm sorry.
我将成为……我将……我将……而且我将……我将……我……我不知道。我很抱歉。
I'm not I'm going to be I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to I'm going and I'm Oh my
我不是……我将成为……我将……我将……我将……我将……而且我……哦，我的
Oh Oh I'm gonnae. And... ...and... ...and... ...and... Oh, I'm
哦，哦，我将……而且…………而且…………而且…………而且……哦，我……
Oh, and Oh. And Oh, She was the mrs. There are ...
哦，而且哦。而且哦，她是夫人。有……
... ... ... ... ... ... ... ...
……………………………………
I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to We're going to be able to be.
我将能够成为。我将成为。我将成为。我将能够成为。我将成为。我将成为。我将……我们将能够成为。
I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to I'm going to be. One of the I'm going to be the
我将成为。我将成为。我将成为。我将成为。我将……我将成为。其中一个……我将成为……
I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be the I'm going I'm I'm going to be able to be.
我将成为。我将成为。我将成为。我将成为……我将……我……我将能够成为。
I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to be. . I'm going to be able to be. I don't know. I'm sorry,
我将成为。我将成为。我将能够成为。我将成为。我将能够成为。我不知道。我很抱歉，
I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to I'm going I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to be. I'm going to be.
我将……我将……我将……我将……我将……我将……我将成为。我将成为。
I'm going to be a man. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm sorry. I don't know. And...
我将成为一个男人。我将成为。我将成为。我很抱歉。我不知道。而且……
And... Oh, oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh, oh.
而且……哦，哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦，哦。
Oh. Oh. And I'm . So, I'm gonnae. And... ...and...
哦。哦。而且我……所以，我将……而且…………而且……
...and... ...and... I don't know. I'm sorry. I'm Oh, so on the Oh, and so on Oh, and
……而且…………而且……我不知道。我很抱歉。我……哦，所以关于……哦，等等……哦，而且……
you know, I don't know. Oh. Oh. Oh. I'm going to be able to be. Thank you. I'm gonna be it.
你知道，我不知道。哦。哦。哦。我将能够成为。谢谢。我将成为它。
And... ...that... ...and... ...and... I don't know. I'm going to be able to I'm going to I'm going to
而且…………那个…………而且…………而且……我不知道。我将能够……我将……我将……
I'm going to I'm going to I'm I'm going on. I'm Thank you. I am.
我将……我将……我……我将继续。我……谢谢。我是。
I am. I am. We're going to be able to be. We're going to be able to be. I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be able to be.
我是。我是。我们将能够成为。我们将能够成为。我将能够成为。我将成为。我将成为。我将能够成为。
I'm going to be. I'm going to be. Thank you. This episode is brought to you by the Philharmonia Orchestra, who are turning 80 this year. And to celebrate, they are giving away 80 free tickets for first-timers for every concert in their 20-25-26 London season. Now, if you've never booked with the Philharmonia before, you can choose any concert in their London season. They're all at the South Bank Centre. you can get two tickets completely free.
我将成为。我将成为。谢谢。本期节目由爱乐乐团（Philharmonia Orchestra）为您带来，他们今年 80 岁了。为了庆祝，他们为 2025-26 伦敦演出季的每一场音乐会提供 80 张免费门票给首次观看的观众。现在，如果您以前从未预订过爱乐乐团的演出，您可以选择他们伦敦演出季的任何一场音乐会。它们都在南岸中心（South Bank Centre）。您可以完全免费获得两张门票。
There is no catch. Just world-class music live. So the Philharmonia's first concert was in 1945 and ever since then they have been a part of Britain's cultural fabric, constantly evolving and always ambitious. They have scored more than 150 film soundtracks and video game soundtracks. They've collaborated across all kinds of genres, classical icons, jazz, they've even done heavy metal.
没有任何附加条件。只有世界级的现场音乐。所以爱乐乐团的第一场音乐会是在 1945 年，从那时起，他们就一直是英国文化结构的一部分，不断进化，始终雄心勃勃。他们为超过 150 部电影原声带和视频游戏原声带配乐。他们跨越了各种流派进行合作，古典偶像、爵士乐，他们甚至做过重金属。
I mean, this is not just orchestral, it is adventurous. So, this is your chance to experience one of Britain's great orchestras and some of the world's top soloists in one of the world's great venues to book. Head to philharmonia.com.com.com.com.U.K. slash free tickets. Come for the music, stand for the ovation. This episode is brought to you by Hotels.com. Make your next trip work for you. Hotels.com just rolled out a game-changing feature called Save Your Way, and it's as simple as it sounds.
我的意思是，这不仅仅是管弦乐，它是冒险的。所以，这是您在世界伟大的场馆之一体验英国伟大的管弦乐队和世界顶级独奏家的机会。预订请访问 philharmonia.com.com.com.com.U.K. 免费门票。为音乐而来，为掌声而留。本期节目由 Hotels.com 为您带来。让您的下一次旅行物有所值。Hotels.com 刚刚推出了一项改变游戏规则的功能，名为“Save Your Way”，听起来很简单。
When you book a trip as a Hotels.com member, you decide how to use your savings. Choose to take the instant savings now or to bank the savings as rewards for later. It's your call. Envision converting discounts on this week's day into rewards for a luxurious beach getaway next year. No complicated maths, no blackout dates. Just you choosing how to make your travels work harder for you. Only at Hotels.com. Save Your Way is available to loyalty members in the US and UK on hotels with member prices.
当您作为 Hotels.com 会员预订旅行时，您可以决定如何使用您的积蓄。选择现在享受即时折扣，或者将积蓄存为以后的奖励。由您决定。设想将本周住宿的折扣转换为明年豪华海滩度假的奖励。没有复杂的数学，没有不适用日期。只有您自己选择如何让您的旅行更划算。仅在 Hotels.com。“Save Your Way”适用于美国和英国的忠诚度会员，适用于带有会员价格的酒店。
Other terms apply. See site for details. This episode is brought to you by NordVPN. Christmas should be a time for relaxing and letting loose, but history teaches us that letting our guards down could allow bad actors to strike. Fortunately, in 2025, we don't need a turret or a moat to stay safe. We just need NordVPN. At the click of a button, NordVPN's powerful software encrypts your data
适用其他条款。详情请见网站。本期节目由 NordVPN 为您带来。圣诞节应该是放松和释放自我的时间，但历史告诉我们，放松警惕可能会让不法分子有机可乘。幸运的是，在 2025 年，我们不需要炮塔或护城河来保持安全。我们只需要 NordVPN。只需点击一下按钮，NordVPN 强大的软件就会加密您的数据，
and Threat Protection Pro blocks malicious links and scans downloads for viruses. It covers up to 10 devices or can be attached to your router to protect your whole home. It also helps with your Christmas shopping. Online retailers can sneakily change prices based on your location. Fortunately, using NordVPN means you can buy presents with the peace of mind that you're getting the best price. To get the best discount of your NordVPN plan, go to NordVPN.com forward slash rest is history. Our link will also give you four extra months on the two-year plan. There's no risk with Nord's 30-day money-back guarantee. The link is in the podcast episode description box.
“威胁防护 Pro”（Threat Protection Pro）会拦截恶意链接并扫描病毒下载。它最多可覆盖 10 台设备，或者可以连接到您的路由器以保护您的整个家庭。它还有助于您的圣诞购物。在线零售商可以根据您的位置偷偷更改价格。幸运的是，使用 NordVPN 意味着您可以安心购买礼物，确保获得最优惠的价格。要获得 NordVPN 计划的最佳折扣，请访问 NordVPN.com/restishistory。我们的链接还将为您提供两年计划的额外四个月服务。Nord 的 30 天退款保证没有任何风险。链接在播客剧集描述框中。
This episode is brought to you by Ancestry. Hello, James Holland here joined by Al Murray from Gollhanger's World War II podcast. We have ways of making you talk. These are those odd days between Christmas and New Year. The house buzzing with laughter, leftovers pile. High, festive films murmuring in the background, and trivial pursuit debates still raging round the table. It's the perfect time to sit close, share family stories and think about people who came before you. Grandparents, great uncles, aunts you hardly knew, everyone who helped shape the family you're part of today.
本期节目由 Ancestry 为您带来。你好，我是詹姆斯·霍兰德（James Holland），与来自 Gollhanger 二战播客“We Have Ways of Making You Talk”的阿尔·默里（Al Murray）一起。这是圣诞节和新年之间那些奇怪的日子。房子里充满了笑声，剩菜堆积如山，节日电影在背景中低语，琐事追求的辩论仍在桌子周围激烈进行。这是坐在一起、分享家庭故事和思考先辈的绝佳时机。祖父母、叔祖父、你几乎不认识的阿姨，每一个帮助塑造了你今天所属家庭的人。
With an ancestry membership, you can take those conversations further. All you have to do is provide what you know about your family history, such as your parents and grandparents' birthplaces, and ancestry will help you dig through billions of records to uncover fascinating news stories about the lives of your relatives. Maybe it's a great uncle ferrying a hurricane north, a grandmother stitching uniforms in a Glasgow mill, or a relative holding the line on the Normandy beaches, and suddenly the stories around your own table take on a whole new depth.
有了 Ancestry 会员资格，您可以将这些对话进行得更深入。您所要做的就是提供您所知道的关于您家族史的信息，例如您父母和祖父母的出生地，Ancestry 将帮助您挖掘数十亿条记录，以揭开关于您亲人生活的迷人新闻故事。也许是一位将飓风战斗机运往北方的叔祖父，一位在格拉斯哥工厂缝制制服的祖母，或者一位在诺曼底海滩坚守阵地的亲戚，突然间，您餐桌周围的故事就有了全新的深度。
The past isn't behind you, it runs straight through you. Head to ancestry.com.uk slash new year to learn about ancestry's memberships and start your family history journey today. I can't tell you what a privilege it is to be actually on the stage listening to such virtuosity, such an honour. So thank you, Leia. Just amazing.
过去并没有留在您身后，它直接贯穿于您。请访问 ancestry.com.uk/newyear 了解 Ancestry 的会员资格，并立即开始您的家族史之旅。我无法告诉您，能真正站在舞台上聆听如此精湛的技艺是多么荣幸，真是莫大的荣幸。所以谢谢你，莱娅。真是太棒了。
So, Dominic, Chikovsky's marriage. I think we've established, he's very much not. the marrying kind of a guy. So what's going on there? I mean, does he think it's his duty? He's got to lie back and think of Russia. What's going on? Yeah. Chikovsky felt the pressure of social expectation, basically. I think he felt that he ought to get married, that it was the thing to do whether he wanted to or not. So already in 1868 he had proposed to a soprano called Desire Artoe, which I think is a sensational name for a soprano. Right. And she says yes.
所以，多米尼克，柴可夫斯基的婚姻。我想我们已经确定了，他非常不是那种会结婚的人。那么那里发生了什么？我的意思是，他认为这是他的责任吗？他必须躺下并想到俄罗斯。发生了什么？是的。柴可夫斯基感受到了社会期望的压力，基本上。我想他觉得他应该结婚，无论他是否愿意，这都是该做的事情。所以早在 1868 年，他就向一位叫德西蕾·阿托（Desire Artoe）的女高音求婚了，我认为这是一个非常轰动的女高音名字。没错。她答应了。
Yes, she did, but it very quickly, I think much to his relief, fizzled out and she married somebody else. But then in 1877, he started getting letters from a young woman called Antonina Milikova. And she had very briefly been a student of his, a music student. Now, Chikovsky had completely forgotten her, but she had certainly not forgotten him. She had developed this great crush on Chikovsky. And she's basically starts sending her these letters. She's a super fan, I suppose. And he agrees to meet her. And at the second meeting, I think very recklessly, he asks her to marry him. And immediately she says, oh, yes. Brilliant. And Tchaikovsky thinks, I have made a huge mistake. And so the wedding when it happens
是的，她答应了，但它很快就平息了，我想这让他松了一口气，她嫁给了别人。但后来在 1877 年，他开始收到一位叫安东尼娜·米利科娃（Antonina Milikova）的年轻女性的来信。她曾短暂地做过他的学生，一名音乐学生。现在，柴可夫斯基已经完全忘记了她，但她肯定没有忘记他。她对柴可夫斯基产生了极大的迷恋。她基本上开始给他写这些信。我想她是个超级粉丝。他同意去见她。在第二次见面时，我想非常鲁莽地，他向她求婚了。她立刻说，哦，是的。太棒了。柴可夫斯基想，我犯了一个巨大的错误。所以当婚礼发生时
is not 100% the kind of wedding that a bride dreams of, is it? Because they get married in Moscow in July 1877. And when the priest says to Chikovsky, you may kiss the bride, Chikovsky responds by bursting into tears. Yes. Yeah, so the wedding night's not a bundle of laughs either. Because as soon as they reach the hotel, Chikovsky, in sort of desperation, takes a massive sedative and goes straight to sleep. And poor Antonina has no idea what's going on. But it's fair to say nothing much is going on. Right. Because a few days later, Shikovsky writes to his brother and he says, look, I find my wife
并不是百分之百新娘梦寐以求的那种婚礼，对吧？因为他们于1877年7月在莫斯科结婚。当牧师对柴可夫斯基说“你可以亲吻新娘了”时，柴可夫斯基的反应是放声大哭。是的。没错，所以新婚之夜也没什么可乐的。因为他们一到酒店，柴可夫斯基就出于某种绝望，服用了大量的镇静剂，直接睡着了。可怜的安东尼娜根本不知道发生了什么。但公平地说，确实什么也没发生。没错。因为几天后，柴可夫斯基写信给他的兄弟说，看，我觉得我的妻子
absolutely repulsive. And Shikovsky capable of great charm, but not on this occasion. No, not on this occasion. So he's very miserable. He's made a terrible mistake. He thinks about throwing himself into the river Moskba, but in the end, he basically flees to the countryside and leaves
极其令人反感。柴可夫斯基虽然很有魅力，但这次却没有。不，这次没有。所以他非常痛苦。他犯了一个可怕的错误。他想过跳进莫斯科河，但最终，他基本上逃到了乡下，留下了
Antonina behind. And not just to the countryside, right? I mean, he basically goes on a massive European holiday. So he goes to Paris, to Florence, to Rome, to Vienna, desperately trying to think of ways to avoid her. And then in the middle of all this, I mean, it should really have been his honeymoon. His great love interest, Joseph Kotech,
安东尼娜。而且不仅仅是去乡下，对吧？我的意思是，他基本上去了一次大规模的欧洲度假。所以他去了巴黎、佛罗伦萨、罗马、维也纳，拼命想办法躲避她。而在这一切中间，我的意思是，这本应该是他的蜜月。他伟大的爱慕对象，约瑟夫·科特克，
pitches up in Switzerland to see him, which I imagine doesn't help with his kind of, I should really get back with my wife kind of thoughts. So you may remember from a few moments earlier that we said Kotech was a violinist. So this is actually the moment that inspires Schaikovsky to write the piece that we have just heard, the violin concerti. And when you listen to it, you can feel there's this kind of incredible sense of excitement.
出现在瑞士看他，我想这对他那种“我真的应该回到妻子身边”的想法没什么帮助。所以你可能还记得刚才我们说过科特克是一位小提琴家。所以这实际上是激发柴可夫斯基创作我们刚刚听到的那首曲子——小提琴协奏曲的时刻。当你听它的时候，你能感觉到一种难以置信的兴奋感。
So, I mean, a musicologist must hate this kind of talk, but perhaps there's a sense there of the frenzy of passion that he's feeling for Kotech. But also, it's a little bit mad, isn't it? Yeah. And maybe that's the effects of his marriage. Well, here's a really mad thing. So the mad thing is that that piece that we've just heard played so brilliantly got one of the worst reviews in the history of classical music from the great Viennese critic of the day,
所以，我的意思是，音乐学家一定讨厌这种说法，但也许其中有一种他为科特克感受到的那种狂热激情的意味。但这也有一点疯狂，不是吗？是的。也许这就是他婚姻的影响。好吧，这里有一件真正疯狂的事情。疯狂的事情是，我们刚刚听到的那首演奏得如此精彩的曲子，却得到了古典音乐史上最糟糕的评论之一，来自当时伟大的维也纳评论家，
Edwa Hanslick. Hanslick said that listening to that was like being in hell. He said, Chikovsky has proved for the first time the hideous notion that there can be music that stinks to the ear. I mean, that is mad. Well, I mean, Thomas, we often tell rival podcasters, rival history podcasters. You should never let the critics get you down. That's so true. So, too. So, Dominant, just two questions, and I'm guessing the answer to both these questions is no. Did they ever consummate their relationship? They did not. And did they ever get back together?
爱德华·汉斯利克。汉斯利克说听那首曲子就像身处地狱。他说，柴可夫斯基第一次证明了那个可怕的观点，即存在着一种让耳朵发臭的音乐。我的意思是，那太疯狂了。好吧，我的意思是，托马斯，我们经常告诉竞争对手播客，竞争对手历史播客。你永远不应该让评论家让你失望。这太对了。太对了。那么，多米尼克，只有两个问题，我猜这两个问题的答案都是否定的。他们圆房了吗？他们没有。他们复合了吗？
Again, they did not. So he went back to Russia, he asked Antonina for a divorce. She said no. They separated, but they didn't divorce. He did give her financial help later in life. And they did sometimes meet, but he was always, I have to say, very cold and almost a little bit cruel when they met. And actually, by and large, when people talk about the great company, They always overlook or indeed a downright rude about the wives.
同样，他们没有。所以他回到俄罗斯，向安东尼娜提出离婚。她说不。他们分居了，但没有离婚。他后来确实在经济上帮助了她。他们有时也会见面，但我必须说，当他们见面时，他总是非常冷漠，甚至有点残忍。事实上，总的来说，当人们谈论伟大的作曲家时，他们总是忽视，甚至对他们的妻子非常粗鲁。
So perhaps we should spare a thought for Antonina. She had a really rough time through no fault of her own. She actually ended up going mad and ended up in a lunatic asylum. So it's a very sad story. And there's kind of sense that meeting Tchaikovsky isn't always great for your long-term mental stability here, isn't it? And I wonder, Dominic, whether it was worse for Anthony, precisely because she had been such a fan. And they separate, just as Tchaikovsky is about to embark on the kind of, you know, the absolute pinnacle of his career, so the 1880s.
所以也许我们应该为安东尼娜想一想。她经历了一段非常艰难的时期，这并不是她的错。她最终疯了，住进了精神病院。所以这是一个非常悲伤的故事。而且有一种感觉，遇见柴可夫斯基对你的长期心理稳定并不总是好事，不是吗？我想知道，多米尼克，这对安东尼娜来说是否更糟，恰恰因为她曾是他的忠实粉丝。他们分开了，就在柴可夫斯基即将开启他职业生涯的巅峰时期，也就是1880年代。
He's become a massive national, actually an international celebrity. And people are comparing him to Mozart and saying that he can turn his hand to anything. Well, I mean, not anything, obviously not marriage. No. But symphonies, concertos, ballets, you name it. Basically, Tchaikovsky can do it. Very Mozart. Yeah, and this is not just a question of Tchaikovsky's genius.
他已经成为了一位巨大的全国性，实际上是国际性的名人。人们把他比作莫扎特，说他什么都能做。好吧，我的意思是，不是什么都能做，显然婚姻不行。不。但交响曲、协奏曲、芭蕾舞剧，应有尽有。基本上，柴可夫斯基都能做到。非常有莫扎特的风范。是的，这不仅仅是柴可夫斯基天才的问题。
It's also a question of the context. So in the 1880s, Russia obviously has some pretty major political issues which culminate in the Russian Revolution, but culturally, it's a very rich and self-confident and sophisticated place. Now, the Tsar at the time Alexander III is a massive reactionary, and he is very keen on the idea that Russia is distinct from the rest of Europe, that it's sort of set apart by its Slavic history and identity. And so for Alexander and his court,
这也是背景的问题。所以，在1880年代，俄罗斯显然有一些非常重大的政治问题，最终导致了俄国革命，但在文化上，它是一个非常丰富、自信和复杂的国家。当时沙皇亚历山大三世是一个巨大的反动派，他非常热衷于俄罗斯与欧洲其他国家截然不同的想法，认为它因其斯拉夫历史和身份而与众不同。因此，对于亚历山大和他的宫廷来说，
The idea that Chikovsky is a distinctly Russian composer with a distinct Russian style, borrowing from traditional folk melodies and songs and whatnot, that becomes really, really important to them. Despite the fact that this is exactly the kind of thing that is going on in countries across Europe. So Sibelius is doing it. Vaughn Williams in New Course will do it.
柴可夫斯基是一位独特的俄罗斯作曲家，有着独特的俄罗斯风格，借鉴了传统的民间旋律和歌曲等等，这种想法对他们来说变得非常非常重要。尽管这正是欧洲各国正在发生的事情。所以西贝柳斯在做，沃恩·威廉姆斯当然也会做。
So what does the Tsar say to that? But the Tsar doesn't give a damn about that time, I think it's fair to say. So the Tsar to the Tsar, he doesn't give a damn what Sibelius is doing. all that matters to him is that Chikovsky is a sort of authentic Russian hero. So in 1884, he invites Chikovsky to St. Petersburg to receive the order of St. Vladimir. Extraordinary honor for a composer. He gives him a ring as a personal present.
那么沙皇对此怎么说呢？但我觉得公平地说，沙皇当时根本不在乎。所以对沙皇来说，他根本不在乎西贝柳斯在做什么。对他来说，唯一重要的是柴可夫斯基是一位地道的俄罗斯英雄。因此，在1884年，他邀请柴可夫斯基去圣彼得堡接受圣弗拉基米尔勋章。这对作曲家来说是极大的荣誉。他给了他一枚戒指作为个人礼物。
And he also gives him a lifetime pension, which is a sign of just how much Chikovsky is valued. So putting the marriage to one side, his life is pretty good. So he's got his pension, he's got his kind of honor. He's very popular. he's kind of famous and he even has a kind of very well actually the kind of perfect patron who's a woman called Nadejde von Meck
他还给了他终身养老金，这标志着柴可夫斯基有多么受重视。所以把婚姻放在一边，他的生活相当不错。所以他有养老金，有荣誉。他非常受欢迎。他很有名，甚至还有一位非常完美的赞助人，一位叫娜杰日达·冯·梅克的女士。
and she's the perfect patron because they never meet but she just chucks loads of money at him and also he's a massive star in America isn't he? Right so he's actually very like us he goes to New York in 1890 he conducts at Carnegie Hall he loves it
她是完美的赞助人，因为他们从未见过面，但她只是给了他大量的钱，而且他在美国也是一位巨大的明星，不是吗？没错，所以他其实很像我们，他在1890年去了纽约，在卡内基音乐厅指挥，他很喜欢那里。
the thing he loved most when he came back and he couldn't stopped talking about. It was the telephone in his hotel. He was amazed by this telephone. And he kept ringing the reception just to kind of try out the phone. Very like Theo Young-Smith on our American tours ringing for room service. He was never off the telephone, was he? And then when he gets back home from America, he gets to work on one of the most joyous and celebrated things that he ever wrote. And that is his ballet, The Nutcracker. And the good news, Dominic, ladies gentlemen
他回来后最喜欢、谈论最多的事情。是酒店里的电话。他对这个电话感到惊讶。他不停地给前台打电话，只是为了试用电话。非常像我们美国巡演时的西奥·杨-史密斯，总是打电话叫客房服务。他总是离不开电话，不是吗？然后当他从美国回到家时，他开始创作他写过的最欢乐、最著名的作品之一。那就是他的芭蕾舞剧《胡桃夹子》。好消息是，多米尼克，女士们先生们
is that we are now going to hear two of its most glorious moments right now the sad news is that we are not going
我们现在要听其中两个最辉煌的片段，坏消息是我们不会
to dance to it but you can't have everything right right We've got... ...because ...and...
跟着跳舞，但你不能拥有一切，对吧？没错，我们有……因为……和……
...you know... ...that... ...and... ...and... ...and ...so... ...and ...a...
……你知道…………那…………和…………和…………和……所以…………和……一个……
...and ...and Oh, I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm gonna be, D. And...
……和…………和……哦，我将会能够。我将会。我将会。我将会，D。和……
I'm on the I'm... ...and... ...a... ...and... ...and... ...and... ...and...
我在……我…………和…………一个…………和…………和…………和…………和……
...a... ...and... Oh. Oh. Oh. Mm. Mm. Mm.
……一个…………和……哦。哦。哦。嗯。嗯。嗯。
Mm. Mm. Mm. Mm. Mm. Oh. Oh. Oh.
嗯。嗯。嗯。嗯。嗯。哦。哦。哦。
Oh. Thank you. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm gonnae. And so on the I'm gonnae'n't I'm gonna'n't
哦。谢谢。我将会。我将会。我将会。等等，我将会……我将会……
We're going to go to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. We're going to do. I'm going to be able to be. ...their... ...and... ...their...
我们要去。我将会。我将会。我们要去做。我将会能够。……他们的…………和…………他们的……
...and... ...the... ...that... ...you... ...the... So that of course was the dance of the sugar plum fairy and the Russian dance, both from the Nutcracker and Dominic, it's starting to feel a lot like Christmas, isn't it? Because, of course, the nutcracker, the story of a wooden nutcracker doll that comes to life at Christmas. Yes, and that was first performed in St. Petersburg in December 1892.
……和…………那…………那…………你…………那……所以那当然是糖梅仙子之舞和俄罗斯舞曲，都来自《胡桃夹子》，多米尼克，感觉很有圣诞气氛，不是吗？因为，当然，《胡桃夹子》是一个木制胡桃夹子玩偶在圣诞节活过来的故事。是的，它于1892年12月在圣彼得堡首次演出。
So at the time, Chikovsky was 52 years old. He was at the peak of his powers, the peak of his popularity. And he's probably got, what, 20 years ahead of him writing unimaginable masterpieces. But just a year later, his story takes a tragic twist. So on the 10th of October, 1893, Chikovsky arrives in St. Petersburg by train, and he's planning to stay with his younger brother, who we've already mentioned, Modest. And Dominic, we're going to be talking about the history of St. Petersburg in a couple of weeks on the podcast, because, of course, we're doing Peter the Great, and St. Petersburg is founded by Peter the Great,
当时，柴可夫斯基52岁。他处于他力量的巅峰，受欢迎程度的巅峰。他可能还有20年时间来创作难以想象的杰作。但仅仅一年后，他的故事就发生了悲剧性的转折。所以，1893年10月10日，柴可夫斯基乘火车抵达圣彼得堡，他计划和他年轻的弟弟，也就是我们已经提到的莫杰斯特住在一起。多米尼克，我们几周后会在播客中谈论圣彼得堡的历史，因为，当然，我们要讲彼得大帝，而圣彼得堡是由彼得大帝建立的，
on very marshy, very boggy land, a lot of mosquitoes, and so it is notoriously, unhealthy, isn't it? Right. It's always been plagued by cholera outbreaks, one of which is raging in the autumn of 1893, and all the restaurants have been told by the authorities that they have to boil their water before giving it to the customers. But 10 days into his stay, the 20th of October, Shikovsky goes out with his mates on the Nevsky Prospect, and they go into a restaurant, and he asks for water. And the waiter says, we've just run out of all the boiled water. If you Hold on a little while, we'll get you some more. Chikovsky says, I don't want to wait.
在非常泥泞、非常沼泽的土地上，有很多蚊子，所以它以不健康而闻名，不是吗？没错。它一直受到霍乱爆发的困扰，其中一次在1893年秋天肆虐，当局告诉所有餐馆，在给顾客水之前必须煮沸。但在他逗留的第10天，10月20日，柴可夫斯基和他的朋友们在涅瓦大街上，他们走进一家餐馆，他要水。服务员说，我们刚用完了所有的开水。如果你等一会儿，我们会给你弄些更多的。柴可夫斯基说，我不想等。
I'm very thirsty. I'm sure it's fine. Just bring me a glass of unboiled water. You can probably guess what's coming. The next day, he complains of feeling unwell. He says, don't call a doctor. I'm sure it'll be fine. Three days later, by the time they do call a doctor,
我很渴。我相信没事的。就给我一杯没煮过的水吧。你可能猜到接下来会发生什么了。第二天，他抱怨感觉不舒服。他说，别叫医生。我相信会没事的。三天后，当他们真的叫医生时，
it's obvious it's not fine. And so it is that at 3 in the morning, on the 25th of October, 1893, Piotr Iliic Chikovsky died of kidney failure. Or did he? Because, Dominic, you know I love a mad conspiracy theory. You do. And it's fair to say that even at the time,
很明显情况不妙。于是，在1893年10月25日凌晨3点，彼得·伊里奇·柴可夫斯基死于肾衰竭。或者真的是这样吗？因为，多米尼克，你知道我喜欢疯狂的阴谋论。你确实喜欢。而且公平地说，即使在当时，
there were people who were skeptical of this whole unboiled water story, and they said that Chikovsky would never make such a stupid mistake, and therefore there must be a more sinister explanation. And actually, you've said how Mozart was Chakofsky's great, hero. There are elements here, aren't there, of the rumors that start to spread around Mozart's death, the possibility that perhaps he'd been murdered. And aren't there historians who kind of dabble in these kind of waters about Tchaikovsky? There are indeed, yes, who dabble in these murky waters. So a very good example is an eminent British historian biographer called David Brown, and he suggested
也有人对这个“没煮过的水”的故事持怀疑态度，他们说柴可夫斯基永远不会犯这种愚蠢的错误，因此一定有更阴险的解释。事实上，你已经说过莫扎特是柴可夫斯基伟大的英雄。这里有一些关于莫扎特死亡传言的元素，不是吗？即他可能被谋杀了。难道没有历史学家在柴可夫斯基的这些事情上涉足吗？确实有，是的，涉足这些浑水。所以一个很好的例子是一位杰出的英国历史学家传记作家大卫·布朗，他建议
that Chikovsky had taken poison, that he'd killed himself under pressure from his old schoolmate. He said basically a schoolmates had convened this court of honor and they had handed down their verdict that Chikovsky must either take the decent way out or they would expose the secrets of his sex life. And what credibility do you give to this theory? You know my methods, Tom. I find this very unconvincing. You see, first of all, Chikovsky doesn't strike me as a man who is haunted by guilt or anxiety or fear in the autumn of 1890. Actually, he's on Cloud 9. He's just finished his sixth symphony. He's in very good form.
柴可夫斯基服了毒，他在老同学的压力下自杀了。他说基本上同学们召集了这个荣誉法庭，他们做出了裁决，柴可夫斯基要么选择体面的方式离开，要么他们就会揭露他性生活的秘密。你对这个理论有多少信任度？你知道我的方法，汤姆。我觉得这非常令人难以置信。你看，首先，柴可夫斯基在1890年秋天并不像一个被内疚、焦虑或恐惧所困扰的人。事实上，他正处于云端。他刚刚完成了他的第六交响曲。他状态非常好。
Actually, I think behind all this, people struggle with, I think, the idea that a superstar, an international celebrity of this kind, an artist, could be cut down by something so random and so meaningless and banal. And I think people also struggled at the time, especially with the idea that cholera,
事实上，我认为在这背后，人们难以接受的是，一位超级巨星，这种国际名人，一位艺术家，竟然会被如此随机、毫无意义和陈腐的事情所击倒。而且我认为当时人们也难以接受霍乱，
which was a disease that afflicted the kind of urban poor, the starving masses, could have carried off such a great man. I think they found that very hard to reconcile. Now, for me, I think probably he did have cholera. I think the boiled water story, as bizarre as it is, is probably true. Anyway, what we do know is that his funeral was a massive deal. It was the first commonest funeral ever to be held
这是一种折磨城市贫民、饥饿大众的疾病，竟然带走了一位如此伟大的人。我认为他们觉得这很难调和。现在，对我来说，我想他可能确实得了霍乱。我认为那个开水的故事，尽管很离奇，但可能是真的。无论如何，我们所知道的是，他的葬礼是一件大事。这是有史以来第一次在圣彼得堡喀山大教堂举行的作曲家葬礼，
at the Kazan Cathedral in St. Petersburg, and it's a sign of his celebrity and his importance that 60,000 people applied for tickets. So that's Tchaikovsky, not just. us dead, but now buried. And Dominant, I wonder, can you give us your verdict on Tchaikovsky? Where does he stand in the history of music?
6万人申请门票，这标志着他的名气和重要性。所以这就是柴可夫斯基，不仅是我们死了，而且现在埋葬了。多米尼克，我想知道，你能给我们对柴可夫斯基的评价吗？他在音乐史上处于什么地位？
So, a lot of people would see him. Well, he's undoubtedly Russia's most beloved composer. I think there's a very good argument that he's Russia's greatest composer. There have always been critics who have dismissed him as a bit lightweight or a bit easy, as a bit too audience-friendly. I don't think that's a bad thing, by the way,
所以，很多人会这样看他。好吧，他无疑是俄罗斯最受爱戴的作曲家。我认为有一个很好的论点，他是俄罗斯最伟大的作曲家。一直有评论家认为他有点轻量级或有点简单，有点太迎合观众了。顺便说一句，我不认为这是一件坏事，
being audience-friendly. I know you don't, darn it. The comparison with Mozart, I think, is a good one. I think nobody since Mozart could do so many different things so quickly and so skillfully. And more broadly, Chikovsky has come to represent the idea, the musical idea of a Russian soul, the idea of Russia itself, sort of torn between Europe and Asia, east and west, all of that stuff. And he would have loved that, wouldn't he? Because he was a massive patriot.
迎合观众。我知道你不这么认为，该死。我认为与莫扎特的比较是恰当的。我认为自莫扎特以来，没有人能如此迅速、如此熟练地做这么多不同的事情。更广泛地说，柴可夫斯基已经代表了一种理念，一种俄罗斯灵魂的音乐理念，俄罗斯本身的理念，在欧洲和亚洲、东方和西方之间挣扎，所有这些东西。他会喜欢这个的，不是吗？因为他是一个伟大的爱国者。
His country meant so much to him. What was the thing he was saying about? He said that I've never come across anyone who loved Mother Russia more than I did. Right, exactly. So basically, he is to Russia, well, you are to Britain. Oh, Tom. Love it. Thank you.
他的国家对他意义重大。他说了什么？他说，我从未见过比我更爱俄罗斯母亲的人。没错，完全正确。所以基本上，他之于俄罗斯，就像你之于英国。哦，汤姆。喜欢这个。谢谢。
That's very kind. That's kind. You're welcome. You're welcome. Well, to capture that, there is one work, of course, above all. And this is the work that really captures, I think, is Russian patriotism. And it was commissioned in 1880 for the opening of the Cathedral of Christ the Savior in Moscow. And this cathedral had been commissioned years before, hadn't it?
你太客气了。你太客气了。不客气。不客气。好吧，为了捕捉这一点，当然有一部作品高于一切。这就是真正捕捉到，我认为，是俄罗斯爱国主义的作品。它于1880年受委托为莫斯科基督救世主大教堂的落成而创作。这座大教堂是几年前委托建造的，不是吗？
And it was designed to serve as a memorial. to the sacrifices made by the Russian people in their defeat of the invasion by Napoleon, which had happened in 1812. Napoleon had occupied Moscow, but had been defeated by the Russian strategy and by the winter, and had been forced to retreat in terrible circumstances,
它旨在作为纪念碑。纪念俄罗斯人民在击败拿破仑入侵中所做出的牺牲，那发生在1812年。拿破仑占领了莫斯科，但被俄罗斯的战略和冬天击败，并被迫在可怕的情况下撤退，
had ended up getting frostbite and eating frozen horses and all kinds of things, and you look gutted at this failure of French strategy, Dominic. Absolutely devastating. History is regular. and listen to the rest of this you will know, is littered with French catastrophes. And this is one of the most purely enjoyable. Anyway, Tchaikovsky, he agreed to write a short piece of music for the opening ceremony,
最终冻伤并吃冷冻马匹和各种东西，你看着法国战略的失败感到沮丧，多米尼克。绝对是毁灭性的。历史是规律的。听听剩下的部分，你会知道，充满了法国的灾难。这是最纯粹令人愉快的灾难之一。无论如何，柴可夫斯基，他同意为开幕式写一小段音乐，
and this piece captures the whole story of the 1812 campaign. So you get the kind of melodies of the Russian Orthodox Church, you get folk tunes, you get Tom, the strutting bombast of the Marseillaise. Strutting bombats. You get bells, you get gunfire. You get celebrations and you even get cannons. So it's literally a banger, ladies and gentlemen. By far, Chikovsky's most popular work
这段音乐捕捉了1812年战役的整个故事。所以你得到了俄罗斯东正教的旋律，你得到了民间曲调，你得到了汤姆，马赛曲的傲慢夸张。傲慢的夸张。你得到了钟声，你得到了枪声。你得到了庆祝，你甚至得到了大炮。所以这简直是一首劲歌，女士们先生们。到目前为止，柴可夫斯基最受欢迎的作品
and I think there is no better piece with which to close his story and this half. Right, well, before we have the music, let me just remind you that we were back after the interval in the second half with the life of Richard Wagner. Now, can I just ask, are there any members here of the Restis History Club? Well, that's very good to know.
我认为没有比这更好的曲子来结束他的故事和这一半了。好吧，在听音乐之前，让我提醒你们，我们在中场休息后回到下半场，讲述理查德·瓦格纳的生活。现在，我可以问一下，这里有“其余是历史”俱乐部的成员吗？好吧，很高兴知道。
And as always, the good news for you club members is that you can hear that second half right away. You don't have to wait. Add free. But I'm afraid the rest of you will have to wait until after the interval. It's such a bargain, isn't it, Dominic? It's such a bargain.
而且一如既往，对你们俱乐部成员的好消息是，你们可以立即听到下半场。你们不必等待。无广告。但我恐怕你们其他人必须等到中场休息后。这真是太划算了，不是吗，多米尼克？这真是太划算了。
But for now, we leave you with Oliver Zephman, with the Philharmonia Orchestra, and with Chikovsky's 1812 overture. Thank you. ...and... ...that... ...their... ...and...
但现在，我们把你们留给奥利弗·泽夫曼，爱乐乐团，以及柴可夫斯基的《1812序曲》。谢谢。……和…………那…………他们的…………和……
...there... ...and... ...and... ...and... ...and... ...b... I don't know. I'm
……那里…………和…………和…………和…………和…………b……我不知道。我
I don't know. I'm going to be able to be. I'm I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to be. We're going to be able to be able to be. I'm .
我不知道。我将会能够。我……我将会能够。我将会。我们将能够能够。我……
And... ...and ...and ...and ...and ...and ...and ...
和…………和……和……和……和……和……和……
... ... We're going to be able to be able to be. We're going to be the mrs. I'm We're going to be.
…………我们将能够能够。我们将成为夫人。我……我们将成为。
I'm going to be. The POMAYOR. I don't know. I'm going to be able to be. We're going to be able to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be.
我将会。市长。我不知道。我将会能够。我们将能够。我将会。我将会。
I'm going to I'm going to And... ...and... ...theirred... ...with... ...which... ...the...
我将会……我将会……和…………和…………他们的…………和…………这…………那……
...with... Thank you. We're going to be the same. We're going to be able to be. I'm going to be. We're going to be able to do. We're going to be able to be.
……和……谢谢。我们将成为一样。我们将能够。我将会。我们将能够做。我们将能够。
And so on. We're going to be able to be. We're going to be able to be. I'm going to be. I don't know. And so, you know, and
等等。我们将能够。我们将能够。我将会。我不知道。所以，你知道，和
the I'm . ...whoe, and ... ...and... ...that... ...and... ...the...
那……我…………谁，和…………和…………那…………和…………那……
...and... ...and... ...you're... I don't know I'm going to be able to I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to
……和…………和…………你……我不知道我将会能够……我将会……我将会……我将会
I'm I'm going I'm I'm going to be able to be. I don't know I'm gonnae'n't know I'm gonnae'n't I'm
我……我将会……我……我将会能够。我不知道我将会……知道我将会……我
know And so, I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to be able to be. And... ...you know,
知道。所以，我将会能够。我将会……我将会……我将会能够。和……你知道，
...and... ...withal... ...you know. ...and... ...and... ...that... ...and... ...the...
……和…………总之……你知道。……和…………和…………那…………和…………那……
...and... ...and... ...and... ...and... I don't know. And... ...withal... ...and...
……和…………和…………和…………和……我不知道。和……总之……和……
...their... We're going to be able to be. We're going to be. I'm going to be. I don't know I'm gonnae'n't know I mean... ...when...
……他们的……我们将能够。我们将成为。我将会。我不知道我将会……知道我的意思是……当……
...their... ...and... ...the... ...the... ...that... ...you know... ...and... ...and...
……他们的…………和…………那…………那…………那……你知道…………和…………和……
...and... We're going to be able to be. And so on. We're going to be able to be. . And... ...then... ...their...
……和……我们将能够。等等。我们将能够。……和…………然后……他们的……
...their... ...you know? ...the... ...the... ...and... ...the... ...or... ...the...
……他们的…………你知道？……那…………那…………和…………那…………或…………那……
We're going to be able to be. I don't know. I'm sorry. So, you know, I'm going to I'm going to be able to be.
我们将能够。我不知道。对不起。所以，你知道，我将会……我将会能够。
I'm gonna'a. ...andahe . ... ... ... ... ...
我将会…………和………… …… …… …… ……
... ... ... ... ... ... ... ...
…… …… …… …… …… …… ……
...hehran... ...for... ...and... ...and... ...the... ...the... We're going to be able to be. And so on,
……他……为了……和…………和…………那…………那……我们将能够。等等，
we're going to be. And so on, you know, We're going to be able to go. I'm going to go. We're going to be able to be able to be. We're going to be able to be. We're going to be able to be.
我们将成为。等等，你知道，我们将能够去。我将会去。我们将能够能够。我们将能够。我们将能够。
We're going to be able to be. ...andemps... ...and... ...withal... ...when... ...their... ...and... ...and...
我们将能够。……和…………和……总之……当……他们的…………和…………和……
...the... ...an... Thank you. Thanks so much for listening. We will be back on Thursday in 2026, our first episode of the year, and that will be with the second half of that show that we recorded at the Royal Albert Hall. And the focus of the show will be the most controversial of all classical composers, Richard Wagner.
……那……一个……谢谢。非常感谢收听。我们将在2026年的周四回来，这是我们今年的第一集，那将是我们在皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅录制的节目的下半部分。节目的重点将是所有古典作曲家中最具争议的理查德·瓦格纳。
I hope you enjoy it. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Hello, I'm Professor Hannah Frye. And I'm Michael Stevens, creator of Vsauce. We thought we would join you for a moment, completely uninvited. We are not going to stay too long, unless you want us to, of course. We're here to tell you about our brand new show.
希望你喜欢。再见。再见。你好，我是汉娜·弗莱教授。我是迈克尔·史蒂文斯，Vsauce的创作者。我们想不请自来地加入你们一会儿。我们不会待太久，除非你希望我们待久一点。我们来这里是为了告诉你们我们的新节目。
The rest is science. Every episode is going to start with something that feels initially familiar. And then we're going to unpick it and tear it apart until you no longer recognize it at all. Yeah, banana flavor doesn't taste like bananas. Yeah, what is that about? So it is supposed to taste like an old species of banana that was wiped down in a banana apocalypse. And now you will only find it in botanical collections in the gardens of billionaires. Wow. Banana candy is actually the ghost of a long extinct banana.
“其余是科学”。每一集都将从一个最初感觉熟悉的事情开始。然后我们将把它拆开，撕碎，直到你完全认不出它为止。是的，香蕉味尝起来不像香蕉。是的，那是怎么回事？所以它应该尝起来像一种古老的香蕉品种，在香蕉末日中被消灭了。现在你只能在亿万富翁花园的植物收藏中找到它。哇。香蕉糖实际上是早已灭绝的香蕉的幽灵。
So if you like scratching the surface, thinking a little bit deeper or weirder. Yes, definitely that too. You can join Michael and I every Tuesday and Thursday wherever you go. get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以如果你喜欢挖掘表面，思考得更深一点或更奇怪一点。是的，绝对也是那样。你可以每逢周二和周四加入迈克尔和我，无论你在哪里获取播客。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。